one minute you're setting up a new space
station orbiting Jupiter the next you're
plunging right into the middle of a
giant Red Cyclone of death
what would the storm of all storms look
like on the inside
how would it compare to storms back on
Earth
and which one of Jupiter's tremendous
forces would strike the lethal blow
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into Jupiter's Great
Red Spot
the Great Red Spot is the biggest storm
in the solar system
at about 16 300 kilometers wide well
it's large enough to swallow the Earth
whole
it's a lot like a hurricane only instead
of lasting a few weeks this giant storm
has been rampaging for at least 300
years
and instead of forming from warm air
this monstrosity gets its energy from
the dense atmosphere of Jupiter
fueled by an abundance of the planet's
hydrogen and helium
the Great Red Spot reaches 500
kilometers into its atmosphere
uh oops you should have built your space
station a little farther away
okay well first how on Earth would you
even get to Jupiter
well if you traveled light and followed
the root of the Voyager spacecraft you'd
arrive on Jupiter in just under 600 days
but this journey wouldn't be as simple
as just pointing yourself at what
appears to be a very bright star in the
night sky
roaming the solar system in a spaceship
is a little more complicated than that
you see the Voyager never intended to
land on Jupiter only to pass it on the
way to Interstellar space
so if you followed voyager's path you'd
whip right past your target
for this to work you'd need to follow
the lead of the Galileo spacecraft
launched in 1989
just like Galileo you'd swing by Venus
and then back around Earth for a little
gravity assist
this way you'd have the right speed to
park in Jupiter's orbit
only the trip would now take you six
years instead of 600 days
by the time you reached Jupiter's moon
Europa the planet would appear 22 times
larger to you than a full moon did back
on Earth
and you'd still need to get a little
closer
now you'd be mesmerized by the planet's
Swirls and Stripes
these are colored red brown and white
thanks to the sunlight reflecting off
massive clouds made of ammonia and
ammonium sulfide
finally you'd Feast your eyes on the
Great Red Spot a giant twirl of the
atmosphere rotating counterclockwise it
looks a lot bigger than you could
imagine
but before you even begin your descent
into the great red unknown your life
would already be in grave Danger
Jupiter's powerful magnetic field would
shower you with intense radiation
I mean luckily you'd be equipped with a
highly Advanced protective suit but it
wouldn't be able to protect you from
everything
as you approached the storm you'd
realize that you made a big mistake in
your mission prep
your plan was to build your space
station at the same altitude as the
International Space Station
400 kilometers into Jupiter's atmosphere
yeah except this storm is as deep as 40
Mariana trenches
so it would swallow you up before you
could finish your project
ah but now it's too late you'd be
plummeting through the storm and you'd
get your first real glimpse of how
powerful it is
you'd be thrown around at wind speeds of
about 400 kilometers per hour
to give you a sense of how insanely
powerful that would be hurricanes are
ranked into five categories based on
strength a category one storm has wind
speeds up to 153 kilometers per hour
strong enough to snap large trees
in the middle a category 3 hurricane can
hit 208 kilometers per hour
storms could result in devastating
damage including pulling roofs right off
of houses
lastly a category 5 hurricane back on
Earth has wind speeds of 252 kilometers
per hour or higher
that packs enough of a punch to
collapsed buildings but that's still
only half as strong as the winds in the
Great Red Spot
thankfully your body can withstand wind
gusts as high as 800 kilometers per hour
but that doesn't mean it would be
refreshing in any way
without the protective face gear your
skin would look as if it was milking
sprayed off of your food
so make sure to hold on to that helmet
tight
not that you'd be able to do much else
besides staying on a violent downward
trajectory at this point
as you were falling into Jupiter you'd
see how clouds around you would change
first you'd get a real close-up view of
those ammonia and ammonium sulfide
clouds you were mesmerized by before
then you'd pass through clouds made of
water
just like the ones on Earth
the temperature and pressure all around
you would be changing too
sadly none of this would be comfortable
for you especially not at the same time
where the atmospheric pressure is
similar to that of sea level back on
Earth it would be a very chilly minus
110 degrees Celsius
and where the temperature was bearable
the pressure would be eight times
greater than what it was back on Earth
now the chances of surviving up to this
point would be slim I mean look no
further than the Fate suffered by the
Galileo probe as it descended further
and further into Jupiter it encountered
extremely high temperatures
and what do you think happens to a probe
in that environment yeah it vaporizes
without a spacesuit strong enough to
withstand all that heat and pressure
you'd end up disintegrating just like
the probe
now you'll be one with the gas giant
forever
what if Jupiter gained just a little bit
more mass during its formation period
and then ignited to become a star
how different would our solar system
have turned out would having another
star in the middle of the solar system
mess with the orbits of the planets and
would we see it from here
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter became a star
Jupiter has more than twice the mass of
all the planets in the solar system
combined
it doesn't have a solid ground and is
made up of the same elements as the sun
and yet it's not a star
Jupiter doesn't have enough Mass to
initiate a fusion reaction in its core
the necessary requirement to be accepted
into the star Club
if only we could find 79 more Jupiters
and crash them all into the one we have
now we'd be able to build a second star
in the solar system
what would that be like
80 Jupiters crushed together would make
a star out of the gas giant but that
star would be nothing like the sun
Jupiter would be massive enough to
become a red dwarf a small cool hydrogen
burning star
and as every red dwarf out there it
wouldn't be too bright 0.3 percent of
the sun's Luminosity is the most light
that Jupiter could hope to spit out
because Jupiter is four times further
away from us than the sun the Earth
wouldn't get much heat from it
by and large Jupiter turning into a red
dwarf wouldn't change anything for life
on Earth
you'd still be able to see it from Earth
a Jupiter star would appear red and a
bit brighter than the moon at its full
phase
would it at least have a gravitational
impact on the solar system
not as much as you might think the
former gas giant would slightly shift
the orbits of the other planets but not
enough to set them on a collision course
with one another or to launch them out
of their orbits into outer space
the only threat we'd face would be space
rocks from the asteroid belt that
Jupiter might send towards the Earth
we'd need to learn how to detect and
Destroy them before they could reach our
planet
other than that not much would change
for the solar system
things would get a lot more fun if
Jupiter was replaced with a sun-like
star
if our gas giant became 1000 times more
massive the solar system would go wild
asteroids would crash into planets and
planets would change their orbital
course
it's hard to predict what would happen
to Earth in this gravitational mess
it could be anything from being pulled a
little too close to Jupiter star and
getting scorched to being left drifting
alone in the void of space
in any case it wouldn't be too pretty
in the real world Jupiter is forever
destined to be a planet and that's for
the best
the observable universe has a diameter
of about 92 billion light years
within it are planets nebulas asteroids
the list goes on but what would happen
if we got rid of a single planet
specifically our largest planet Jupiter
how important is this gas giant to our
solar system
how would it affect life on Earth
and how would this change Earth's
development
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter never existed
if Jupiter was no longer in our solar
system
having one less planet to Aspire to
travel to would be the last thing we'd
have to worry about this gas giant
ranges from 600 to 1 000 million
kilometers away from Earth
but despite it being so far away from us
we'd experienced direct implications
right here on Earth
why is this
well to say that we'd notice Jupiter's
absence here on Earth is a bit of an
understatement
this is due to Earth not being around at
least not in the current state as we
know it today
sure it would still be some sort of
Planet but it's very unlikely that there
would be any complex life forms no fish
animals and certainly no humans
Earth has been hit by tons of asteroids
and other space rocks
According to some experts they may have
brought water and other essential
substances down to earth
but although some asteroids can be good
there's plenty of bad ones some would be
big enough to wipe out entire
civilizations
just like what happened to the dinosaurs
65 million years ago
this is where Jupiter's role comes in
although it has slipped up a couple of
times throughout the history of our
Solar System Jupiter has been protecting
us
as millions of asteroids have been
heading towards Earth Jupiter's
gravitational pull has grabbed the
asteroids
this puts them in Jupiter's orbit and
unable to reach Earth
without our giant protector Earth would
be hit by a lot more asteroids
and it's unlikely that another planet
would step in to fill Jupiter's place
considering that the gas giant is the
only planet big enough to attract all
these asteroids
this means Earth would get hit by
thousands more asteroids than it ever
has before
some would be small and could maybe help
Earth bringing us new elements
but it's possible Earth would get hit by
a couple of big ones
enough to destroy anything that would be
evolving on the planet
and maybe enough to destroy Earth itself
so we know we probably wouldn't be here
if Jupiter had never existed but what if
it suddenly disappeared today
our solar system would have developed in
the exact same way but Jupiter suddenly
blinked out of existence
for more on how our solar system as a
whole would shift and get all out of
sorts you can check out our episode what
if Earth was the only planet in our
solar system
but if only Jupiter disappeared it might
be a good thing
despite being our protector occasionally
Jupiter messes up and might miss a
couple of things
Jupiter threw a comet towards us 350
years ago
luckily it missed us but it wouldn't
have been anywhere near Earth in the
first place if it wasn't for Jupiter
despite Jupiter occasionally throwing
some space rocks our way
it has largely helped us throughout
history
so I'm gonna say it's probably best to
let Jupiter stay in our galaxy
Jupiter may be the biggest planet in the
solar system but its days are numbered
because today we're using Earth's
biggest baddest bombs to blow the gas
giant into Oblivion
how many nukes would you need to do the
job
what obstacles would these rocket-bound
bombs encounter on the way
and would one nuclear explosion ignite
the entire planet
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we nuked Jupiter
nuclear weapons are so powerful that
even the low-yield versions like those
dropped on Japan by the United States in
World War II have the explosive
equivalent of 15 to 20 kilotons of
dynamite each
what makes them so volatile is that they
harness the intense energy releasing
power of nuclear fission or Fusion
these are the same processes that happen
in our very own Sun
so be careful when moving these things
out to Jupiter one false move and you
could be incinerated by a fireball as
hot as the center of the Sun
in order to blow Jupiter to bits one
single bomb wouldn't necessarily be up
for the task
good thing for this scenario that there
are a lot of nuclear weapons on Earth
maybe the safest plan would be getting
them all off our planet anyway
given the top secret nature of military
activities it's hard to know the exact
number but estimates put the global
Arsenal at about 12 700 with the United
States and Russia battling for top spot
with 5500 to 6 000 weapons each
okay there's no use in delaying let's
get these rockets off Earth as fast as
possible
the distance between Earth and Jupiter
fluctuates from about 590 million to
970 million kilometers
in the past missions like the Galileo
space probe took nearly five years to
make the journey to the gas giant
but our Rockets wouldn't take this long
Galileo had to be slow enough to enter
Jupiter's orbit we just need to hit the
planet head on so you'd only be looking
at about 550 to 650 days to get the job
done
you shouldn't be too Reckless and Speedy
though you don't want to Nuke something
else by accident
now bypassing the moon and Mars would be
easy enough but getting safely through
the asteroid belt would be like
navigating a minefield
there are millions of asteroids riddled
between Mars and Jupiter and while the
average distance between them is a not
so worrisome 966 000 kilometers
sometimes it can still get a little
cramped in there and Jupiter is partly
to blame for this
planet's massive gravitational influence
causes many of these to group into
clusters known as families carelessly
navigate through one like the Flora
family and you'd better hope none of our
Rockets would collide with any of its
400 asteroids
for the best chance of success you
should aim to transport your Rockets
through the Kirkwood gaps these are
nearly asteroid-free regions in the belt
because you'd hate to see all of our
planet's nukes detonate themselves in a
blinding Chain Reaction before reaching
our Target
as the first of our bombs exploded on
Jupiter you'd see bright flashes back
here on Earth just like when the
Shoemaker Levy 9 Comet slammed into
Jupiter in 1994.
but that only released five percent as
much energy as the Tsar Bomba the
largest bomb ever created
so with thousands of our nuclear bombs
Jupiter's days would have to be numbered
right
well not exactly even though our nukes
could produce an explosion hotter than
the sun this wouldn't cause all the
hydrogen on Jupiter to ignite it just
isn't dense enough to sustain nuclear
fusion
and even if every bomb was detonated
Jupiter wouldn't blow up completely
either
in order to do that we'd need to unleash
as much energy as the sun releases over
160 years all at once and for that
highly energetic result about 1 billion
billion nukes would be required
somewhat more than the 12 700 in our
Arsenal
to build that many bombs you'd need a
combined mass of material that would
almost be twice that of the largest moon
in the solar system
Jupiter's Ganymede
no small feat since it's bigger than
Pluto and Mercury
ever feel like the Earth is just too too
small well let's make it bigger much
much bigger welcome to A New Earth that
is just as big as Jupiter
in what ways would Earth change
what things would stay the same
and how would this affect you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Earth were the size of Jupiter
a super Earth is a planet with a mass up
to 10 times bigger than the earth
but don't let the name deceive you these
super Earths aren't anything like the
Earth you know
these planets could be Rocky or covered
entirely in ice
they could even be gacious like Neptune
but if you want to make the Earth as big
as Jupiter get ready to make a super
super super Earth while Earth as it
exists now is much smaller than Jupiter
it is a pretty dense Rock compared to
the gas giant our new planet would be
massive
about 1300 times bigger than Earth today
and that's not the only thing that would
be different
Jupiter has a radius about 11 times that
of Earth
get used to a little more gravity when
you walk around
yeah 11 times more
so if Earth was this huge how soon would
the gravity completely crush your body
this change in size would have enormous
implications for you and all other life
on Earth
the first thing you'd notice with 11
times the surface gravity is that you
would weigh more and there's not much a
diet plan could do to change that you'd
be 11 times heavier than you are now
so if you currently weigh 70 kilograms
well get ready to start lugging a hefty
770 kilograms around
would you even be strong enough to carry
your own weight
well you'd be heavier than the world
deadlifting record of 501 kilograms held
by Game of Thrones star half Thor
bjornsson so yeah good luck but if you
were a couch potato this could be good
news
getting up from the couch wouldn't be an
option you wouldn't have the muscle
strength even breathing would be a near
impossible task
scientists have concluded that the
maximum gravitational field that humans
could adapt to is about five times the
gravity of Earth
well now double that and that would be
your new normal
and you wouldn't be the only one feeling
heavier all that gravity would result in
increased atmospheric pressure yeah
you'd feel the air pressing down on you
this would have severe environmental
impacts
water molecules would need more energy
to escape their liquid form
that means the boiling temperature of
water would be much higher than 100
degrees
and the freezing point would now be way
below zero degrees
it would be harder for you to make ice
and even the large chunks of ice like
icebergs could Melt Away
and there would be disruptions Beyond
life on the surface of Earth
introducing a massive Planet into the
solar system would create some serious
instabilities
our moon would experience extreme
changes in Tidal forces
this gravity could be strong enough to
pull the moon apart into teeny tiny
pieces
the only Remnant you'd have left would
be a new ring of debris forming around
Earth
the sun would still be 250 times more
massive than our new Earth so Earth
wouldn't steal any planets away but our
super Earth could have some effect on
their orbit just as Venus and Jupiter
impact our orbit and climate today
the Earth would affect the orbits of
other celestial bodies like asteroids
our gravitational pull could be strong
enough to eject these objects from the
asteroid belt and set them on a
collision path with you
and that would be bad news remember you
wouldn't be able to move a muscle to
escape
so maybe it's better if Earth stays the
same size as it is now uh oh looks like
somebody left the gas running on Jupiter
don't do anything stupid like lighting a
humongous match
what would a match need to be made of to
ignite this gas giant
how big would it have to be
and how much damage would this explosion
do to our solar system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lit a match on Jupiter
okay you've heard me say this before
Jupiter is the largest planet in our
solar system it's 300 times more massive
than Earth but it's less dense than our
home
with no solid surface this planet is
almost entirely gaseous
it has an atmosphere composed of 90
hydrogen about 10 percent helium and
Trace Amounts of methane and ammonia
with so much hydrogen present pretty
much all of Jupiter must be flammable
right
so if you lit a match
how much of that wooden stick would burn
off before it all goes kaboom
okay before you go ahead and strike that
match there's one big catch you didn't
account for
fire needs oxygen
without any Oxygen in Jupiter's
atmosphere it would be impossible for
the planet to erupt in flames
not only that but lighting your match
would be difficult to say the least
usually when you drag a Matchstick
across the red strip on your matchbox
you start a series of small chemical
reactions that end in a flame
when you apply friction to the Box red
phosphorus converts to white phosphorus
this mixes with the oxygen in the air
and ignites without oxygen this ignition
wouldn't happen
but since you're so determined to set
Jupiter on fire you'd have to find a way
around this obstacle
for starters you'd need to reinvent the
matchbox
you'd need one that could ignite the
match without the need for external
oxygen in the atmosphere
so you could lose the white phosphorus
in your match
instead you'd need a match that could
generate enough heat from friction to
break down potassium chloride on the
Matchstick into oxygen
the flame would keep burning as long as
the Matchstick coating lasted
but one Matchstick wouldn't provide you
with the oxygen you'd need to ignite
Jupiter you'd need a lot more
again considering that Jupiter is the
most massive planet in our solar system
you'd be burning off an astounding
amount of hydrogen
to be precise about
1.4 multiplied by 10 to the power of 27
kilograms of the stuff
for hydrogen to combust you'd need about
half as much oxygen present in the
atmosphere as there is hydrogen as you
might have guessed you'd need to gather
a lot of oxygen and because molecules of
oxygen are way heavier than molecules of
hydrogen the total mass of oxygen we'd
need would be about six times the mass
of Jupiter yeah there isn't enough
oxygen in the entire solar system for
this to happen
sorry to disappoint you but Jupiter
won't be erupting in Flames anytime soon
and before you try to get creative with
your methods let me tell you that even
the most energetic impact that ever
occurred on the gas giant didn't cause a
single spark in 1994 the comet Shoemaker
Levy 9 crashed into Jupiter
as it entered the atmosphere it broke
into multiple pieces some were as large
as one kilometer in diameter
the total impact of all these pieces was
massive
so massive that the total kinetic energy
was many times more powerful than the
Hiroshima nuclear bomb
but still no flames
still feeling destructive well maybe you
could see what would happen if Jupiter
and Saturn collided
the two biggest planets in our solar
system in one telescope view
catastrophe is imminent
if Jupiter and Saturn suddenly were on a
collision course
which of the two planets would emerge
Victorious
how would the composition of these
planets affect the outcome
and what impact would this have on the
rest of our solar system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter and Saturn collided
on December 21st 2020 Jupiter and Saturn
were closer than they've been in nearly
400 years
this legendary event has an epic name
the great conjunction
planets in the same telescope View
they appeared as a single star in the
evening sky
but they were still pretty far from an
astronomical Collision
if the two gas giants came a little
closer it wouldn't be the first time
Jupiter has gone head to head with
another planet and you can probably
guess who won that battle
both Jupiter and Saturn are almost
entirely geacious
primarily consisting of hydrogen and
helium
and while they may have solid cores
there's no sharp transition between the
layers
Jupiter would have some significant
advantages it's about three times as
massive as Saturn with almost double the
volume and it's moving faster too
Jupiter's rotation speed reaches 13
kilometers per second while Saturn
rotates at just below 10 kilometers per
second but Saturn brings a wild card to
the fight within its two rings there are
at least
150 moons and moonlets if the planets
Drew closer together
Jupiter's strong gravitational pull
would cause these moons moonlits rocks
dust and Ice to accelerate toward it
some of them would be torn apart
that's what happened when the comet
Shoemaker Levy 9 collided with Jupiter
in 1994. originally the comet was nearly
two kilometers wide
but by the time it crashed Jupiter's
gravity had torn it to pieces and those
fragments smashed into Jupiter with the
force of 300 million atomic bombs
yeah and that heated Jupiter's
atmospheric temperature to nearly 40
000 degrees Celsius
Titan Saturn's largest moon is over 2
000 times larger than that Comet so the
force of it alone colliding with Jupiter
would be massive
if Jupiter and Saturn collided they
would begin to merge their atmospheres
would mix that would raise the
temperatures in the top layers of the
gas Giant's atmospheres
it would get so hot that Jupiter would
experience a chemical reaction
gaining more iron silicates and even
water
eventually Jupiter would absorb Saturn
or most of it
scientists at sunyetsen University in
China modeled a scenario about what
happened when a massive planetary embryo
about 10 times the size of Earth
collided with Jupiter four and a half
billion years ago
the impact was so energetic that it
destroyed Jupiter's original compact
core
this formed a more diluted core composed
of a dense mix of liquid metallic
hydrogen and helium but if Jupiter
collided with Saturn that event would be
10 times more massive
large amounts of material would spread
out in space and then all that material
would come together into a single
planetary object
we'd call it new Jupiter or jupiterness
and maybe that new planet would cause
more trouble in the solar system than
you might expect
Jupiter is sometimes referred to as a
failed star that's because its size and
composition are similar to a brown dwarf
but jupiterness would be more massive
and have higher internal pressure
if the temperature was high enough this
could cause nuclear fusion in its core
yeah jupiterness could become a star and
the impact of having two stars in our
planetary neighborhood would be huge
it could even mean the end of life on
Earth
now don't worry if these two planets
merged jupiterness would have a mass 30
percent greater than Jupiter but for
nuclear fusion to ignite the planet
would need to reach a mass of 75
Jupiters
so life on Earth would go on but this
would be a spectacular show with tons of
gas and debris expelled maybe it would
all be illuminated by the sun giving us
a beautiful glittering end to Saturn as
we know it hey at least this time
Jupiter didn't go on a rampage and
swallow every planet in our solar system
including Earth
you start your day hearing wild news
Jupiter has just swallowed Saturn and it
doesn't stop there Jupiter is on its way
to swallow every planet in the solar
system
how big would Jupiter get
what would you see from Earth
and would Jupiter get rings like Saturn
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter swallowed every planet
in the solar system
Jupiter has swallowed a planet before
around four and a half billion years ago
a protoplanet slammed into the young
Jupiter the protoplanet was 10 times
Earth's mass made of Rocky and icy
material
Jupiter's core broke apart and denser
material mixed with hydrogen and helium
a few billion years later the heavy
material settled back into the dense
core that we see today now swallowing a
single planet is one thing but could
Jupiter eat up all seven
in this scenario you're going to see the
planets get swallowed from largest to
smallest although we're saving Earth for
last
Jupiter's first victim would be Saturn
from Earth you could see these gas
giants as two bright stars and if you
were to look up at the night sky as
Jupiter swallows Saturn well all you'd
see is Jupiter getting super bright
but if you were closer to the action
you'd see complete chaos
Jupiter is only three times heavier than
Saturn so it would be swallowing a
planet that's almost its size
first their moons would Collide creating
massive amounts of debris
some Moon remnants would rain down on
Jupiter and some of the debris would
float in space as Jupiter was crashing
into Saturn Jupiter's surface
temperature would become hotter than the
sun's outer layer
whatever remained of Saturn would mix in
with Jupiter's atmosphere they would
become one
now swallowing Saturn would increase
Jupiter's mass and gravity by 30 percent
Jupiter would also sport prominent new
rings from the shattered moons
next it would envelop the two ice giants
Uranus and Neptune the 27 moons of
Uranus would collide with the rings of
Jupiter adding to the floating debris
Uranus has an icy core made of water
methane and ammonia but Neptune's inner
core is Rocky regardless both cores
would melt as the planets crashed into
Jupiter
now Jupiter would be almost 40 percent
heavier and it would head towards its
first Rocky planetary snacks
the rocky planets Venus and Mars
wouldn't even make it to Jupiter's core
they'd burn up in Jupiter's atmosphere
as if they were mere asteroids
then we'd see our last planetary
neighbor disappear inside this bulked up
Jupiter Mercury is even smaller than
Jupiter's largest moon Ganymede so it
would get ripped apart by Jupiter's
Rings adding to the Speedy debris
now only Earth and Jupiter would be left
and Earth would be in big trouble
but how would Jupiter go about
swallowing our planet
you know even in its normal State
without swallowing six planets Jupiter's
gravitational force affects Earth
yeah every 405 000 years the pull of
Jupiter and Venus makes Earth's orbit
wobble it causes hotter Summers colder
Winters and more rainfall in the tropics
and now Jupiter's gravitational pull
would be over 40 percent stronger
but Jupiter's pull would still be no
match for the sun's gravitational force
so Jupiter would have to come for Earth
just like it swallowed all the other
planets in our solar system
Jupiter doesn't have a hard surface like
the rocky planets you could say Jupiter
is a big dense ball of gas
its surface is defined as the point
where its atmospheric pressure is equal
to Earth's well so could Earth simply
pass through
uh no
just like the rest of the planets Earth
and all life on it would be toast first
we'd be bombarded by asteroids while
passing through Jupiter's rings
I doubt anyone would survive this but if
they did they would see the Earth
igniting as it enters Jupiter's
atmosphere Jupiter is so massive that
even if it were to swallow its seven
planetary neighbors it wouldn't even
double in size
[Music]
as our biggest planet
Jupiter's immense presence helps to hold
our solar system together
its massive size and gravitational pull
give it a dense atmosphere a turbulent
mix of hydrogen and helium
this results in unfathomable storms that
have lasted for centuries
but let's imagine Jupiter came in closer
contact with an even bigger object
the sun would the sun strip Jupiter of
its atmosphere and if so what would that
look like
what makes Jupiter such a unique gas
giant
what is Jupiter's core made of
and what are hot Jupiters and hot
Neptunes
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter lost its atmosphere
[Music]
Jupiter's gravity is nearly two and a
half times stronger than Earth's making
it difficult for any atmosphere to
escape
thankfully it also keeps out incoming
asteroids
Jupiter has dense layers of gas
consisting of 90 hydrogen 10 percent
helium and a few traces of ammonia
sulfur methane and water vapor it has an
extended dilute core made up of Rocky
material ice hydrogen and helium
and unlike Earth there's no sharp
transition between Jupiter's core and
its outer atmosphere
scientists believe the core could have
been formed from a head-on collision
about four and a half billion years ago
between Jupiter and a planetary embryo
10 times more massive than Earth
a recent discovery of the exoplanet
ltt9779b by NASA's transiting exoplanet
survey satellite or Tess May unlock even
more answers to Jupiter's formation and
possible destruction
NASA's discovery of the jupiter-like
exoplanet
ltt9779b has captivated the scientific
Community with its miraculously close
orbit to its star while Jupiter
maintains a safe distance from the Sun
[Music]
ltt9779b is so close to its star that
its atmosphere is evaporating at an
accelerating pace
what makes it so unique is that close
orbits are usually reserved for Earth
leg or jupiter-like planets but
ltt9779b is somewhere in between closer
in scale to Neptune
with an ultra hot temperature of about
1725 degrees
astronomers have unimaginatively named
it hot Neptune
oh yeah clever guys
personally I would have gone with the
blue Inferno
astronomers believe that the exoplanet
may have formed further away from its
star and has slowly made its way closer
and closer over millions of years
the closer it gets to its star more and
more of its atmosphere evaporates giving
it a squished almost football-like
appearance
American football
[Music]
ltt977b is losing its atmosphere because
it has surpassed the critical distance
where a planet begins to lose Mass due
to the tidal forces caused by another
Celestial body this is known as the
Roche limit
luckily Jupiter is far enough away from
the Sun to maintain its mass
and its moons are far enough away from
Jupiter not to be absorbed
so why do most gas giants like Jupiter
reside so far away from the Sun
well all planets were built in the same
way the Sun's gravity pulled dust and
rock together
while the sun burned off Gases such as
hydrogen and helium in the inner solar
system the outer parts stayed cool
this provided just the right temperature
and materials for planets to form
atmospheres
some astronomers have suggested that
there are earth-like planets out there
that may have once been gas giants
for unknown reasons they have entered
the Roche limit and lost all their
atmosphere becoming hot Earths
there are even hot Jupiters out there
like the exoplanet 51 Peg
which is similar in scale and orbits its
star every four days
for Jupiter to start losing its
atmosphere it would need to come closer
to the Sun and surpass its Roche limit
while this isn't likely to happen if
Jupiter got nudged toward the sun it
would slowly start to spiral closer and
closer to it it would lose more mass
with each orbit eventually it would get
so close that it would orbit the Sun in
a single day
88 times faster than Mercury's orbit the
sun's strong solar winds would give
Jupiter a tale of gas like a comet this
enormous amount of gas could Cloud the
light of many stars making our night sky
much less impressive
during this slow process Jupiter would
be squished and eventually lose its
atmosphere it would be left looking like
a Barren rocky planet like Mercury but
about the size of 11 Earths
as we continue to explore and discover
more exoplanets like hot Jupiters or hot
Neptunes scientists can better
understand Planet formation which is
vital to our understanding of the
universe
[Music]
the Earth has been hurtling towards
Jupiter for the past
242 days
and now it's about to make impact
now we're so close to the giant planet
that it's the only thing that fills our
sky
ground temperatures on Earth are rising
uncontrollably our atmosphere is
igniting into flames and the scientific
Community is scrambling to provide
answers
what will happen when the two planets
collide
is there any chance that we could pass
right through the gas planet
and how would this Collision transform
Jupiter forever
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter swallowed Earth
one way that scientists could find
answers would be by looking into the
past because this wouldn't be the first
time that Jupiter has collided with
another planet
[Music]
nearly four and a Half Men
vault in in a violent collision with a
planet 10 times the mass of the Earth
in that case the Collision completely
transformed Jupiter's core but what
happened to the other planet
and what can that tell us about our own
planet's chances of surviving a crash
into the gas giant
to get some answers let's travel back to
four and a half billion years ago when
Jupiter was just a young Planet trying
to find its place in the universe
back then Jupiter's gravitational pull
became 30 times more powerful in just a
fraction of a million years
this destabilized the orbits of nearby
infant planets and caused some of them
to crash into Jupiter
it's believed that one such planet was
10 times the mass of Earth
and it was mainly a silicate ice core
the planet hit Jupiter with an impact
speed of 46 kilometers per second
Jupiter only lost a small amount of mass
from the Collision but its original core
was completely changed
before the impact Jupiter had a dense
central core of heavy elements and the
rest of the planet was made up of
hydrogen and helium
after the impact the infant planet's
silicate ice core merged with Jupiters
causing Jupiter's core to become diluted
[Music]
the heavy elements spread out and mixed
with the outer layers of Jupiter
while this Collision was a defining
moment for Jupiter it meant the end of
the road for the other planet
so what are the odds that the Earth's
fate would be any different
well let's find out
[Music]
the Earth orbits around the Sun at an
average velocity of 29.78 kilometers per
second at this speed if the Earth were
to just leave its orbit around the Sun
and head straight for Jupiter it would
take about 242 days to get there
throughout our journey Jupiter would
shine like a bright star growing bigger
day by day hour by hour
by day six Jupiter would appear as
bright as our moon
[Music]
soon we would start to notice our
daylight becoming dimmer we'll only get
about 50 percent of our normal sunlight
when we reach Mars's orbit luckily for
us the Earth's atmosphere would act as a
buffer so we wouldn't experience the
cold right away but that will only last
a while so you'll need to invest in some
heavy duty winter gear to put it in
perspective Mars has a surface
temperature of minus 63 degrees
so that's basically what we'd have to
look forward to
once we speed through Mars's orbit we'll
pass through the asteroid belt
we'll get to see beautiful meteor
showers lighting up the sky but will
also be at risk with colliding with some
of those meteors so let's keep moving
after 242 days of traveling through our
solar system we would finally reach our
destination Jupiter
as the Earth is pulled into Jupiter our
planet's velocity could increase until
it reaches 60 kilometers per second
that's 250 times faster than an airplane
fly so you'll want to hold on tight oh
and did we mention that Jupiter has 79
confirmed moons orbiting it at all times
so there's a serious risk that we could
collide with any of them as the Earth is
pulled in closer
and if we do happen to avoid all those
moons things would only get worse
as we crash into Jupiter both planets
atmospheres will be compressed rapidly
increasing the temperature and
essentially setting the air on fire
but at least we won't have to worry
about colliding with Jupiter's core
because we'll never make it there
our planet is too small and would burn
up in the atmosphere before that ever
happens
[Music]
but this would have a huge impact on
Jupiter as the Earth's remains would
completely mix into its atmosphere
so if you ever notice our planet going
off course and heading towards Jupiter
you might want to jump off along the way
maybe right as we pass over Mars
and if you want any pointers on how to
make the red planet your new home check
out our new show how to survive
the advice you find there might help you
set up your own little martian colony
but that's a story for another what if
[Music]
foreign